okay it's time for morality with
Motamedi let's get right into this
week's moral question to producer Louis
Motamedi here's the set up genetic
enhancement is already possible and will
become more common in the future should
all genetic enhancements be legal and if
not what should be restricted our
designer babies moral Lewis I open it to
you alright
seeing as how I see all of this genetic
work as an inevitability and a legal
inevitability ah I guess let's just talk
about the the legal aspect I I do
believe that it should be legal and it's
going to be very hard to draw the line
somewhere when you're talking about gene
editing because there are so many things
you'll be able to manipulate to change
but address the morality element
specifically well I just I guess I don't
have a problem with it because the way I
see it
that child is primarily going to be
sculpted mentally by the life it its
upbringing rights nurture rather than
nature of course or artificial nature as
the case may be so while you may be able
to increase the physical strength and
prowess of this child reduced diseases
change the hair color maybe the height
maybe the Evi color maybe give maybe
even give this chance a better shot at
having a higher IQ ultimately it's still
the nurture element is still very
important so I would say morally that I
don't have a problem with this I need
any genetic editing at all any genetic
changes you're fine with it all if you
get into some fringe category here where
you're trying to have your kid have a
third eye or something like that that
may be a little extreme yeah I I think
it's easier to draw that legal line when
it comes to something like that but
let's say that you want maybe you want
your child to be unstable maybe you're
trying to give birth to a psychopath
complete lunatic psychopath
or for some reason you were going in the
opposite direction with some of these
things and you are trying to have a
really dumb child or you were trying to
ensure that your child has certain
diseases maybe for the purpose of
researching them maybe for the because
you're crazy or you want your child to
be morbidly obese for some reason I it's
clear why I would have moral objections
to that but I also think that that is
probably where the legal line will be
drawn well one of the bad arguments I
find is the baby can't a fetus or a baby
can't consent to having its body altered
right therefore you shouldn't be able to
as a parent make these decisions
I think they can't even consent to being
born in the first place they can't
consent to be born in the first place
vaccinations have irreversible effects
good or bad depending on whether you're
in the science movement or in the
anti-vaccine movement circumcision I
mean there's so many things and
different people have problems with
these different choices parents can make
but the idea that anything that the
fetus cannot choose is wrong is not a
good argument for me now one of the good
arguments for me against just saying hey
it's open season do whatever you want an
arthur caplan medical ethicists who
we've talked to about this has made is
that you will see classes between
designer and non designer babies created
you're going to see lifespan potentially
increase and the effects of income
inequality are going to become even more
noticeable and and you can make a strong
argument that ethically morally and for
a number of other reasons that's not
good but I think the real question here
is are there specific types of changes
that you find to be immoral let's open
it to the audience and as you know on
the Thursday show we will follow up how
can you draw a distinction without
seeming to be arbitrary in terms of what
you would allow and what you wouldn't
and then some would say well any traits
either the way to divide it is edits
that would be passed on to subsequent
children of that individual should be a
separate group than those that would not
and that that's a way potentially to
divide what should and should not be
allowed but let's open it to the
audience Lewis and
see what they say that's my suggestion